Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. hello welcome to the rest is history we are whistling our way through all the various contenders in this year's world cup and dominic uh portugal one of our favorite countries isn't it we've done four episodes on the history of portugal and we actually left that series on a cliffhanger we did indeed so. So, bom dia, everybody. You'll be treated once again to our splendid Portuguese. We did our four-part Portuguese history series, and we did end on a cliffhanger.
感谢您收听《一切皆历史》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听体验、系列节目的抢先收听权限，以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社群，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎来到《一切皆历史》。我们正在本届世界杯的各路参赛球队中纵情驰骋，多米尼克，葡萄牙——我们最喜欢的国家之一，对吧？我们制作了四期关于葡萄牙历史的节目，而且我们其实是在一个悬念中结束那个系列的。确实如此。所以，bom dia（葡萄牙语：早上好），各位。你们将再次享受到我们那精彩绝伦的葡萄牙语。我们做过四部分的葡萄牙历史系列，而且我们确实以一个悬念收尾。
So, for those people who didn't listen, Tom. Why didn't they listen? Well, obviously, madness. Madness, yes. I won't say stop listening to this, go back and listen to it. Listen to this and then go back and listen to it. But this is a slight spoiler, isn't it? I mean, you're kind of giving away the end.
那么，对于那些没有听过的听众，汤姆。他们为什么不听？好吧，很显然，这是疯了。疯了，是的。我不会说“别听这个了，回去听那个”。先听这个，然后再回去听。但这算是一个小剧透，对吧？我的意思是，你有点把结局给剧透了。
So we described in the final episode how since 1926, Portugal had been ruled by this extraordinary figure, Antonio Salazar, an incredibly conservative, you know, sort of openly, literally reactionary Catholic university professor, who was regarded as a sort of Portugal's great sort of economic mind. And he had presided over as prime minister, this regime that some people would describe as fascist or near fascist. I don't think fascism is quite the right word because it's fascism tries to stir people up salazar was trying to sort of calm things down calm things down to
所以在最后一集中，我们描述了自1926年以来，葡萄牙一直由一位非凡的人物统治——安东尼奥·萨拉查（Antonio Salazar），一个极其保守的、可以说是公开的、字面意义上的反动天主教大学教授，他被视为某种葡萄牙伟大的经济头脑。作为首相，他主持了一个被一些人称为法西斯或接近法西斯的政权。我不认为“法西斯”是完全准确的词，因为法西斯试图煽动民众，而萨拉查则试图让局势冷静下来，让局势冷静到
the point of utter inertia indeed to actually turn the clock back um you know he was sort of still fulminating about how terrible the reformation was in the middle of the 1960s and also wasn't it that um oil gets discovered in angola and they come rushing to tell him the good news and he says how terrible. Yes, exactly. Exactly. So Salazar presided over this regime. And at the end of the 1960s, Salazar had a stroke in August 1968, which basically marks the end of his political hegemony. But Portugal was the backwater of backwaters. It was by far the poorest, the most economically, culturally backward.
彻底陷入惯性的地步，甚至实际上是想让历史倒退。嗯，你知道的，他在20世纪60年代中期还在激烈抨击宗教改革是多么可怕。还有，是不是安哥拉发现了石油，然后他们赶忙把这个好消息告诉他，结果他说“这太糟糕了”。是的，完全如此。完全如此。所以萨拉查一直主持着这个政权。在20世纪60年代末，萨拉查在1968年8月遭遇了一次中风，这基本上标志着他政治霸权的终结。但葡萄牙是落后地区中的落后地区。它是经济上、文化上最贫困、最落后的地方。
I mean, I hate to use the word, but it was as though it was asleep in European terms while everybody else had kind of forged ahead. So the 60s, London's swinging, Soissons-Oastika in paris are throwing cobblestones at police all that kind of stuff exactly portugal's basically in still in the 1860s yeah now we ended that podcast by saying we would do this episode for our world cup series about what happened next about the end of the regime and the so-called Carnation Revolution of 1974, and the extraordinary political turmoil and turbulence that followed as Portugal became a modern democracy. So we should probably start by saying the man who takes over. So when Salazar was kind of knocked out at the
我的意思是，我很讨厌用这个词，但用欧洲的标准来看，它就好像在沉睡，而其他所有人都已经大步前进了。所以在60年代，伦敦在摇摆，巴黎的索邦大学学生在向警察扔鹅卵石，诸如此类。没错，葡萄牙基本上还停留在19世纪60年代。对。我们在那期播客的结尾时说过，我们将在世界杯系列节目中制作这一集，讲述接下来发生了什么，也就是1974年所谓的“康乃馨革命”（Carnation Revolution），以及随后葡萄牙转型为现代民主国家时所经历的非凡政治动荡与混乱。所以我们大概应该从接班人开始说起。因此，当萨拉查在
end of 1968, the man who succeeds him is an old lieutenant of his, yet another incredibly reactionary kind of Catholic academic, who's a guy called Marcello Caetano. And Caetano was a law professor. He'd been the rector of the University of Lisbon. I mean, it's an extraordinary thing. They have this very authoritarian regime through much of the 20th century that is basically run by university professors. And Caetano is exactly that. And he has quite an unenviable inheritance. He looks like he's a bespectacled... They all look the same. They're all kind of bespectacled men in suits. That's what he is. Not only is Portugal very economically backward, and it's obviously politically repressive, but they're also fighting these colonial wars in
1968年底倒台时，接替他的是他的一位老部下，又一个极其反动的天主教学者，一个名叫马尔切洛·卡埃塔诺（Marcello Caetano）的人。卡埃塔诺是一名法学教授。他曾担任里斯本大学的校长。我的意思是，这是一件非凡的事情。他们在20世纪的大部分时间里都拥有这个高度威权的政权，而这个政权基本上是由大学教授运营的。卡埃塔诺正是这样的人。他有着相当棘手的政治遗产。他看起来像个戴着眼镜的……他们看起来都一样。他们基本上都是戴着眼镜穿西装的男人。他就是这样的人。葡萄牙不仅经济非常落后，政治上显然也受到压制，而且他们还在
Africa because Portugal, almost uniquely in Europe, has decided that it is not going to give an inch to the forces of colonial liberation, that it is going to hold on to its colonies. They say, we don't have an empire, we have a global Luciferian community. But how are they affording that? Well, this is the thing. So these wars in Africa, Tom, they're fighting particularly in Angola and Mozambique. By the time Caetano takes over at the end of the 1960s, these wars are consuming about 40% of the Portuguese budget. And the Portuguese budget is pretty small by European standards anyway. So that gives you a kind of sense that they are massively overstretching themselves
非洲打着这些殖民地战争，因为葡萄牙在欧洲几乎是绝无仅有的，它决定对殖民地解放的力量不妥协一分一毫，它要死死守住自己的殖民地。他们说，我们没有帝国，我们有一个全球性的卢西塔尼亚（葡萄牙）共同体。但他们是怎么承担得起这些开销的呢？嗯，关键就在这里。所以，汤姆，这些在非洲的战争，他们主要在安哥拉和莫桑比克作战。到20世纪60年代末卡埃塔诺接掌政权时，这些战争大约消耗了葡萄牙40%的预算。而按欧洲标准来看，葡萄牙的预算本来就很小。所以这就让你有一种感觉，为了打这些战争，他们已经严重透支了自己，
to fight these wars and wars that have become increasingly bloody. So to give you just one example, in the summer of 1973, Caetano was due to visit Britain to mark the anniversary of the Anglo-Portuguese alliance. Our oldest ally, Portugal, something we had talked about at the beginning of our Portuguese series. And to his horror and embarrassment just weeks before he comes to britain a british catholic priest tom i know you love a british catholic priest called adrian hastings he exposes a massacre that has taken place in mozambique at a place called wiriyamu where portuguese commandos have killed about 150 african villagers so it's that classic yeah you know sort of colonial peacekeeping by shooting shooting people that has just gone horribly
而且这些战争变得越来越血腥。举个例子吧，在1973年夏天，卡埃塔诺计划访问英国，以纪念英葡同盟周年。我们最古老的盟友——葡萄牙，我们在葡萄牙系列节目的开头谈论过的事。然而令他惊恐和尴尬的是，就在他访问英国前几周，一个英国天主教神父——汤姆，我知道你喜欢英国天主教神父——名叫阿德里安·黑斯廷斯（Adrian Hastings），揭露了一起发生在莫桑比克一个叫维里亚穆（Wiriyamu）地方的大屠杀，葡萄牙突击队在那里杀害了大约150名非洲村民。所以这就是那种经典的，你知道的，通过射杀、射杀平民来进行的殖民地维和行动，结果却变得一团糟、
horribly wrong and this is terribly embarrassing for kaitan and there's a lot of um stuff in the british press which he finds you know he's very cross about it and all this as he he wants to move the regime um to a slightly more liberal. I mean, you couldn't get less liberal, but he wants to slightly liberalize it. So slight Gorbachev-esque quality. A tiny bit. He eases the press censorship. They have the first independent trade unions that they've had since the beginning of the Estado Novo, since the beginning of the regime.
一团糟，这让卡埃塔诺感到无比尴尬。英国媒体上有很多关于这的事，他对此感到非常气愤，诸如此类。他希望将政权转向稍微开明一点的方向。我的意思是，你找不到比这更不开明的了，但他想稍微自由化一点。所以有点戈尔巴乔夫式的特质。有一点点。他放松了新闻审查制度。他们建立了我新国家（Estado Novo）建立以来、也就是政权建立以来的第一批独立工会。
There's a lot of rural workers who've been shut out of, sort of peasants basically, who've been shut out of social security. And he says, let's give them a pension. So these kinds of things. He wants to show that he's a new broom. But there are two, I mean, apart from the colonial wars, the 1970s is an age of very high inflation because of world commodity prices. So, you know, everybody's under tremendous economic pressure. Then you have the 1973 oil crisis. And basically what happens is that blows him completely off course. And the hardliners in the regime, in the army and so on, they put pressure on him to abandon a lot of these reforms.
有许多被排斥在社会保障之外的农村工人，基本上就是农民，他们一直被排除在外。他说，让我们给他们发养老金。诸如此类的事情。他想展现自己是一个新人。但除了殖民地战争之外，20世纪70年代还有两个问题：由于全球大宗商品价格的原因，这是一个通货膨胀非常高的时代。所以，你知道的，每个人都面临着巨大的经济压力。然后你又遇到了1973年石油危机。基本上发生的情况是，这彻底打乱了他的阵脚。政权内部的强硬派、军队等等，向他施压，要求他放弃大部分这些改革。
They swing back towards- Double down. Yeah, to be reactionary. Now, there's one reform in particular that is absolutely fatal for the regime and it's kind of not what you would expect so obviously the colonial wars the army has expanded and it's very very expensive and um portugal doesn't really have many friends left because it's fighting these extremely nasty colonial campaigns so it's getting sort of advice
他们转回了——变本加厉。是的，变得反动。现在，有一项改革对这个政权来说绝对是致命的，而且这有点出乎意料——显然，殖民地战争导致军队规模扩大，而且非常非常昂贵；而且葡萄牙几乎没有什么朋友了，因为它正在进行这些极其恶劣的殖民地战役，所以它只能从罗得西亚、南非那样的人那里得到某种建议，
from rhodesia from south africa from people like that not from the cia because that's a stereotype isn't it that in the 70s yeah wherever there's a colonial war shadowy cia operatives and we we talked about that in the or maybe we haven't yet talked about it in the euroquai episode we did and in fact the cia or at least the Americans, will come into this story later on. But I don't think it's so – I mean, it's actually not the Americans who are the key players at this moment. It's actually the Rhodesians, so the breakaway white separatist regime,
而不是从CIA（中情局）那里得到，因为那是一种刻板印象，不是吗？认为在70年代，只要有殖民地战争，就会有暗中活动的CIA特工。我们在欧洲国家（Euro-quai）那一集里谈过这个，或者也许我们还没在欧洲那一集里谈过。事实上，CIA，或者至少是美国人，稍后会进入这个故事。但我认为这并不是——我的意思是，在这个关键时刻发挥关键作用的其实并不是美国人。实际上是罗得西亚人，也就是罗得西亚的分裂派白人分离主义政权、
white supremacist regime in Rhodesia, because they say to Caetano, it is very expensive fighting colonial wars, yes. One way you could do it is actually bring into the army and promote. You don't have to go through all this incredibly rigorous training. And you can promote people who've just been in the militia. So people who have maybe served abroad, you can give them, you can treat them as regular officers and promote them and build them up and stuff without having to go through all the expensive years of the military academy and all of that kind of thing first.
白人至上主义政权。因为他们对卡埃塔诺说：“打殖民地战争确实非常昂贵。你可以采用的一个方法，实际上是将人员引入军队并予以提拔。你不必经历所有这些极其严苛的训练。你可以提拔那些仅仅在民兵中服役过的人。所以那些可能在海外服役过的人，你可以赋予他们、将他们视为正规军官并提拔他们、重用他们等等，而不必先经历所有那些昂贵的军事学院学习年限以及诸如此类的事情。”
Cotone says, great, what a good plan. And he passes a law in the summer of 1973 to do this. Now, the issue with this, and it sounds like such a sort of boring bureaucratic thing, but the issue with this is that in Portugal, there are an awful lot of people who couldn't afford to go to university. And so what they would do, they would enter the military academy and that was their way up. That was their way to status and so on. So there's a whole sort of generation of young officers who, for them, being commissioned as an officer after undergoing all this training was a real badge of status it was a source of great pride for their families and they see that their positions and their careers and
卡埃塔诺说：“太好了，真是个好主意。”并在1973年夏天通过了一项法律来做到这一点。现在，问题在于——听起来这似乎是一个枯燥的官僚主义事情——但问题在于，在葡萄牙，有相当多的人上不起大学。所以他们会怎么做呢？他们会进入军事学院，那是他们向上流动的途径。那是他们获得地位等等的途径。因此，有一整代年轻军官，对他们来说，经过所有这些训练后被委任为军官是一种真正的地位象征，是他们家庭的巨大骄傲，而当政府只是随意地把晋升发给所有这些纯粹在民兵中服役过的人时，他们看到自己的地位、职业和声望受到了威胁。
their prestige threatened when the government is just sort of handing out promotions willy-nilly to all these people who've purely been in the militia so there's intense discontent within this sort of whole generation of youngish officers who think, God, I worked really hard for this. And they're just handing them out like baubles. So by the end of 1973, there's a group of junior officers who are thinking, this is rubbish. I'm really cross. The old men have sort of betrayed me and all this sort of stuff. And once you've got that going on, once army officers are kind of meeting to say this kind of thing, that's very dangerous for your regime.
因此，在这整代年轻军官中间存在着强烈的不满，他们觉得：“天哪，我为这个付出了巨大的努力。而他们却像发小饰品一样把晋升随手送人。”所以在1973年底，有一群初级军官在想：“这太荒谬了。我真的很生气。老家伙们背叛了我，诸如此类的事情。”一旦这种情绪开始蔓延，一旦军官们开始开会讨论这种事情，这对你的政权来说就非常危险了。
In dark glasses, presumably. Well, I think some of them are wearing dark glasses. Some of the older ones are wearing dark glasses, Tom. So you get this group of what they call the captains. People call them, so they're kind of quite junior officers. And they become known as the MFA, the Armed Forces Movement. And they start to, in their middle meetings and stuff, they start to say, listen, we should get out of Angola and Mozambique.
戴着墨镜，大概吧。嗯，我想他们中有些人确实戴着墨镜。年纪大一点的有些戴着墨镜，汤姆。所以你得到了这样一群人，他们称之为“上尉们”。人们这样称呼他们，所以他们是相当初级军官。他们被称为MFA，即“武装部队运动”（Armed Forces Movement）。他们开始在他们的内部会议等等场合说：“听着，我们应该撤出安哥拉和莫桑比克。
This is a complete disaster. It's a nasty war. We're clearly not going to win. We should have a new start, you know, new regime, maybe have elections, get rid of the secret police at home, all of these kinds of things. And some of these officers have sort of left-wing ideas and left-wing connections.
这是一场彻底的灾难。这是一场肮脏的战争。我们显然赢不了。我们应该有一个全新的开始，你知道的，建立新政权，也许进行选举，摆脱国内的秘密警察，诸如此类的事情。”其中一些军官有着某种左翼思想和左翼联系。
The Communist Party is still there. It's gone underground, but it has still been there all this time. They also have a figurehead. There's a guy called General Spinola, Antonio Spinola. Now, he is quite a conservative figure. He was in his 60s. Amazingly, he had been a military observer at the siege of Leningrad in the 1940s. Yeah.
共产党依然存在。它已经转入地下，但这段时间它一直都在。他们还有一个名义上的领袖。有一个人叫斯皮诺拉将军（General Spinola），安东尼奥·斯皮诺拉。现在，他是一个相当保守的人物。他当时60多岁。令人惊奇的是，他在20世纪40年代曾担任列宁格勒围城战的军事观察员。啊。
Goodness. With the Germans. Yeah. That seems very out of time. Well, I suppose it is quite out of time, isn't it? Yeah. Yeah. So he'd been the commander in Guinea-Bissau in the late 60s.
天哪。和德国人一起。对。这似乎很不合时宜。嗯，我想这确实很不合时宜，不是吗？是的。是的。所以他在60年代后期曾担任几内亚比绍的司令。
And he said, oh, this is an absolute disaster. You know, this is not a – these African wars are terrible for our international reputation. Loads of our boys are dying. It's incredibly expensive. We're not going to win. And he wrote a book called Portugal in the Future when he came back saying, let's get out of Africa. This is a disaster. He is fired in early 1974 by the regime for doing this.
他说：“哦，这简直是一场灾难。你知道的，这不是——这些非洲战争对我们的国际声誉来说太糟糕了。我们的大量士兵正在死去。这贵得难以置信。我们赢不了。”他回来后写了一本名为《未来的葡萄牙》（Portugal in the Future）的书，里面说：“让我们离开非洲吧。这是一场灾难。”他在1974年初因这样做而被政权解职。
And that, again, is a great error because it gives these grumpy captains a possible figurehead. They've also got a chief strategist who we'll talk about a lot in this podcast. He is a great character. He is a man called Colonel Othello Sariva de Carvalho. And everybody just calls him Othello. Othello, Tom. His name is Othello. But he's not black.
而这又是一个巨大的错误，因为它给这些心怀不满的上尉们提供了一个可能的名义领袖。他们还有一个首席战略家，我们将在本期播客中大量谈论他。他是一个了不起的人物。他是一个名叫奥泰罗·萨里瓦·德·卡瓦略（Colonel Othello Sariva de Carvalho）的中校。每个人都叫他奥泰罗。奥泰罗，汤姆。他的名字叫奥泰罗。但他不是黑人。
Well, he had been born in Lorenzo Marques in Maputo in Mozambique in 1936 to Luso-Goan parents. So parents who were Portuguese Goa. The Portuguese colony that gets taken over in the 60s. And they call him Othello. So in his very name, there's a hint of Portuguese colonial history. And he had served in guinea he'd served in angola bizarrely he'd been photographed weeping over salazar's coffin in when salazar died in a in 1970 and were these were these crocodile tears or genuine tears of grief very
嗯，他于1936年出生在莫桑比克马普托的洛伦索马克斯，父母是葡萄牙裔果阿人。也就是说，父母来自葡萄牙的果阿。那个在60年代被吞并的葡萄牙殖民地。他们给他起名叫奥泰罗。所以从他的名字里，就带着一丝葡萄牙殖民地历史的印记。他曾在几内亚服役，在安哥拉服役，匪夷所思的是，当萨拉查在1970年去世时，他曾被拍到在萨拉查的棺木前痛哭。这些眼泪是鳄鱼的眼泪还是悲伤的真情流露？
hard to tell tom he has a very interesting life and basically at the end of this podcast his life will take a very unexpected twist which i think you will will enjoy. Can't wait. He's a great- He's a great showman. He's a very theatrical figure. And by the early 70s, Othello has become very, very left-wing. And he's the sort of guiding figure. He basically, he's a colonel. He gets all the captains together and he says, listen, we should have a coup. Enough is enough. We should get rid of the old guard, new regime, get out of Africa. So the coup is planned for the night of the 24th and 25th of April, 1974. And it starts in a tremendous way. It starts with two songs on the radio, which are the signals to the captains.
很难说，汤姆。他有着非常有趣的人生，基本上在本期播客结束时，他的人生将经历一个非常出乎意料的转折，我想你会喜欢的。拭目以待。他是一个伟大的——他是一个伟大的表演者。他是一个非常戏剧化的人物。到70年代初，奥泰罗变得非常非常左翼。他是某种指导人物。基本上，他是一名中校。他把所有的上尉们召集起来说：“听着，我们应该发动政变。受够了。我们应该除旧迎新，建立新政权，撤出非洲。”于是，政变计划在1974年4月24日至25日的夜晚进行。它以一种极好的方式开始了。它以收音机里的两首歌开始，这两首歌是给上尉们的信号。
So the first song, Tom, you'll be delighted to hear, is Paulo de Carvalho's song, E depois do adeus, a song I'm sure you know well, because it was Portugal's entry in the 1974 Eurovision Song Contest. Okay, but presumably that would be played quite a lot on the radio, wouldn't it? Well, it's at a particular time. It's the combination of the two songs, you see. Oh, I see.
所以第一首歌，汤姆，你一定会很高兴听到，是保罗·德·卡瓦略（Paulo de Carvalho）的歌曲《告别之后》（E depois do adeus），这首歌我相信你很熟悉，因为它是葡萄牙参加1974年欧洲歌唱大赛（Eurovision Song Contest）的参赛曲目。好吧，但那首歌大概会在收音机里播很多次，对吧？嗯，是在特定的时间。看，这是两首歌的结合，你看。哦，我明白了。
So that's played... And there's only the one channel then? It's not like there's kind of, hello and welcome to Eurovision FM. No, there are multiple radio stations. You have to be listening. Listen, I'm the coup planner. Okay, all right. The coup people have clearly got loads of radio listening to. You see, I would choose a less obvious track.
所以那首歌被播放了……当时只有一个频道吗？不像现在有什么“欧洲歌唱电台，欢迎您”之类的吧？不，有很多广播电台。你必须得收听。听着，我是政变策划者。好吧，好吧。政变策划者们显然听了很多广播。你看，我会选择一首不那么明显的歌。
Well, it's not a very successful Eurovision entry because I checked. It came 16th and it got only three points. Okay. So maybe it wasn't being played very often out of shame. Who knows? Staying on national honour. So at 10.55 in the evening, that is played on Lisbon radio.
嗯，它在欧洲歌唱大赛中并不是一个非常成功的参赛曲目，因为我查过了。它得了第16名，只获得了三分。好吧。所以也许它并没有因为觉得丢脸而经常播放。谁知道呢？为了国家荣誉。所以在晚上10点55分，这首歌在里斯本广播电台播放了。
Because they've already taken it over, have they? Or do they have a kind of, they have a friendly DJ? They have a friendly DJ. They have contacts in the DJ community. So then a few hours later, 20 minutes past midnight, on a different radio station, Radio Renaissance Radio, Tom. On Renaissance Radio, they play a song called Grandola Villa Morena,
因为他们已经接管了电台，是吗？还是说他们有个某种——有个友好的DJ？他们有一个友好的DJ。他们在DJ圈子里有人脉。然后在几个小时后，即午夜过后20分钟，在另一个广播电台——文艺复兴电台（Radio Renaissance Radio），汤姆。在文艺复兴电台，他们播放了一首名为《格兰多拉，黑色的村庄》（Grandola Villa Morena）的歌，
this sort of lament, Grandola, it's called, Grandola is a place. And it's by a sort of protest singer, a folk protest singer called Zica Afonso, very left-wing kind of, who toured Portugal singing these.
这是一种哀歌，叫格兰多拉，格兰多拉是一个地方。这是由一个抗议歌手、一个民谣抗议歌手演唱的，名叫齐卡·阿丰索（Zica Afonso），一个非常左翼的人，他曾在葡萄牙巡回演唱这些歌曲。
Yeah, because these are not the songs that you'd associate with an army coup in the 70s. Eurovision and then a sort of folk, a very mournful folk ballad. Well, we know from our previous podcast, we did one episode, didn't we? We were talking about Fado. The Portuguese love a very mournful song. They do.
是的，因为这些并不是你会与70年代的军事政变联系在一起的歌曲。欧洲歌唱大赛，然后是一种民谣，一首非常哀伤的民谣。嗯，从我们之前的播客中我们知道，我们做过一期节目，不是吗？我们谈论过法多（Fado）。葡萄牙人喜欢非常哀伤的歌曲。他们确实喜欢。
Yes, they do. So the mournful song is played. And this is the sort of the cue. So they've got this particular guy who they said, you lead the troops into Lisbon. He's a guy called Salguero Maya. And he's a captain. He's the son of a railway worker. And he assembles all his troops and he gives a famous speech. And he says, gentlemen, as you all know, there are various forms of state. There are socialist states, there are capitalist states, and there's the state that we are in. And in in this solemn night we're going to put an end to this state so anyone who wants to come with me
是的，他们确实喜欢。所以哀伤的歌曲播放了。这就是某种信号。所以他们有这个特定的人，他们对他说：“你带部队进驻里斯本。”他是一个叫萨尔盖罗·马亚（Salguero Maia）的人。他是一名上尉。他是一个铁路工人的儿子。他集合了所有的部队，并发表了一场著名的演讲。他说：“先生们，正如你们所知，国家的形态多种多样。有社会主义国家，有资本主义国家，还有我们现在身处这样的国家。在这庄严的夜晚，我们要终结这个国家，所以任何想跟我一起走的人，
let's go to lisbon and let's finish it and they all volunteer they pitch up in lisbon at the government quarter at about six o'clock in the morning there's then a sort of scene there's a little bit of shooting but not not actually that much. The government, Caetano and the other government ministers, they hole up at a barracks at the Lago del Camo in the sort of center of town, and they're surrounded by these troops. Most government forces go over to the rebels. So the rebels have it kind of all their own way. So Salguero Maia, who's the captain, the railway worker's son,
我们去里斯本，把它彻底了结。”然后他们全都自愿加入了。他们在早晨6点左右抵达里斯本的政府办公区。接着发生了一些场景，有一点枪声，但实际上并没有那么多。政府成员、卡埃塔诺和其他政府内阁部长们龟缩在市中心卡莫广场（Lago del Camo）的一个军营里，被这些部队包围了。大多数政府部队都倒戈加入了叛军。所以叛军基本上一切顺利。因此，萨尔盖罗·马亚——那位上尉、铁路工人的儿子，
he's leading his men, he's addressing them on a megaphone and all this. Caetano says, I'm not going to surrender to you because you're a mere captain. He says, it would be like throwing my power into the gutter to surrender to a captain. So they go out and they get that old general, the guy from the siege of Leningrad, General Spinola, because he's got the right rank. He pitches up. He accepts the surrender of Caetano. And the government ministers are all led away. And actually, it's pretty bloodless. So is that the coup?
正率领着他的部下，用扩音器向他们发表讲话等等。卡埃塔诺说：“我不会向你投降，因为你区区一名上尉。”他说：“向一个上尉投降，就像把我的权力扔进阴沟一样。”于是他们出去找来了那个老将军——那个经历过列宁格勒围城战的人，斯皮诺拉将军，因为他有正确的军衔。他赶到了。他接受了卡埃塔诺的投降。政府部长们都被带走了。事实上，这是一场相当不流血的政变。所以，这就结束了吗？
We'll never do a podcast with more coups than this episode. We should take a break. No, no. Because you've underestimated the number of coups in the... Oh, God. I've planned the break. No, no. Because you've underestimated the number of coups in the... Oh, God. I've planned the break. It's very exciting. Okay.
我们绝不会做一期比这一集包含更多政变的播客了。我们该休息一下了。不，不。因为你低估了其中的政变数量……哦，天哪。我已经把中场休息计划好了。不，不。因为你低估了政变的数量……哦，天哪。我已经把中场休息计划好了。这太令人兴奋了。好吧。
So only four people were killed that day, and they were shot by the secret police. The crowd, as is always the way when these things happen, great crowds poured into the streets, and they assembled outside the headquarters of the secret police, the PID, shouting and roaring and stuff. The secret police fired at them, killed four people.
所以那天只有四个人丧生，而且他们是被秘密警察开枪打死的。人群——每当这种事情发生时总是如此——大量的人群涌上街头，聚集在秘密警察总部“皮德”（PID）门前，大喊大叫、怒吼着。秘密警察向他们开枪，杀害了四个人。
But by and large, by the standards of coups, this is very, very bloodless. And actually, these are pretty much the only people who die in the whole of this podcast. Now, the thing that becomes the symbol of this sort of semi or nearly bloodless revolution are the carnations, flowers. Now, why does this happen well salgaro maya and his troops when they're sort of going through lisbon they pass a self-service restaurant called sir which was celebrating its its one year anniversary that day the story goes and there i mean this is there is some debate whether this is a slightly apocryphal story that the restaurant had decided that for his anniversary would hand out flowers to everybody
但总的来说，按政变的标准来看，这是非常非常不流血的。事实上，这些几乎是这整期播客中仅有的死亡人数。现在，成为这场半流血或接近不流血革命象征的东西是康乃馨，也就是花朵。现在，为什么会这样呢？嗯，萨尔盖罗·马亚和他的部队在穿过里斯本时，路过了一家名为“塞尔”（Sir）的自助餐厅，据说那天餐厅正在庆祝开业一周年。故事是这样的——这里也有一些争论，这是否是一个稍微有点杜撰的故事——餐厅决定为其周年纪念日向所有来吃午餐的人赠送花朵，
who came for lunch but because of the coup lunch is cancelled so they've just got all these flowers on their hands and uh one of the sort of waitresses who's called celeste caillero she's a left-wing sympathizer and she basically has got our arms full of all these red and white flowers and she thinks oh i'll give them to the soldiers so they put them in the muzzles of their guns oh yes that's very 60s behavior yeah or their tanks and so there's and more flower sellers get come and give them flowers and there's there's flowers everywhere it's lovely there is some suggestion this may be a bit of a myth that's been that's been that's been exaggerated after the event which is a shame i think we should go with it yeah of course we should go purposes
但由于政变，午餐取消了，所以他们手里堆满了这些花。其中一位名叫塞莱斯特·卡略罗（Celeste Caeiro）的女服务员是一位左翼同情者，她基本上怀里抱满了这些红白相间花朵，她心想：“哦，我要把它们送给士兵们。”于是士兵们把它们插在了枪口里——哦，是的，这非常具有60年代的行为艺术风格——或者插在坦克上。于是，更多的花贩赶来送花，到处都是花，这太美妙了。有一种说法认为这可能是一个在事后被夸大的神话，这真有点遗憾，我认为我们还是顺着这个说法讲下去吧。是的，当然我们应该顺着讲下去。为了本集节目的目的，当然我们应该顺着讲下去。所以政变成功了，卡埃塔诺——他到此为止了。他先是被空运到马德拉岛，然后又被空运去了巴西。巴西当时是一个独裁政权，所以基本上任何想去巴西的人都去了巴西。所以他就在那里闲逛，在里约热内卢闲逛，并于1980年死于心脏病发作。
of this episode of course we should go with it so the coup has succeeded caetano that's the end of him he's flown to madeira to start with and then he's flown off to brazil brazil has a dictatorship so basically anyone who wants to go to brazil they go to brazil so he just hangs out there he hangs out and rio de janeiro and dies of a heart attack in 1980. And that is the end of him. Okay. So we can park him. We can forget all about him. Now the guy from the siege of Leningrad, General Spagnola, he was sort of intended to be a vague figurehead for the coup, but not really the main man. But because Caetano wouldn't surrender to a captain and would only surrender to a general,
这就是他的结局。好吧。所以我们可以把他抛诸脑后了。我们可以把他忘得一干二净。现在那个经历过列宁格勒围城战的人，斯帕尼奥拉（应为斯皮诺拉）将军，本来只是打算作为这场政变的模糊名义领袖，而不是真正的主角。但由于卡埃塔诺拒绝向一个上尉投降，而只肯向一个将军投降，斯皮诺拉突然成为了聚光灯下的焦点，他心想：“太好了，太棒了。”于是他实际上成为了共和国的新总统。所以有大量关于他的广播，他身后挂着国旗。没错。金边肩章，军帽。所有这些东西。所有这些东西。没错。
Spagnola is suddenly in the limelight and he thinks, great, fantastic. So he actually becomes the new president of the Republic. So lots of broadcasts with him, flags behind him. Precisely. Gold braid, cap. All that stuff. All that stuff. Exactly.
经典的政变后行为。而且也是非常经典的政变后行为。他是某个名为“全国救国军政府”（National Salvation Junta）的机构的负责人。我的意思是，或者他们在葡萄牙会叫它“洪塔”（Junta），因为他们发J的音。总之，在20世纪70年代，你必须得有一个“洪塔”或者军政府，不是吗？我们只会表现得更开明一点。让我们继续努力吧。一切都很好。但几天之内，正如一贯的那样，革命完全失控了。葡萄牙基本上沉睡了50年，突然在几天之内以一种非常戏剧性的方式醒来。全国各地都有工人们从老板手中接管他们的店铺。在葡萄牙南部的阿连特茹（Alentejo）的大庄园里，所有这些农民，
Classic post-coup behavior. And also very classic post-coup. He's the head of something called the National Salvation Junta. I mean, or I suppose they would say Junta in Portugal because they pronounce the Js. Anyway, so you've got to have a Junta or a Junta in the 1970s, haven't you? We'll just be a bit more liberal. Let's crack on. Everything is great. But within days, the revolution, as is always the way, spirals completely out of control. Portugal has been asleep for basically 50 years and suddenly within days wakes up in a very dramatic way. All across the country, you have workers who are taking over their shops from their bosses. You have all these peasants on the greatest states in the Alentejo in the south of Portugal,
即大庄园制（Latifundia）的土地上，人们说这些简直是几乎完好无损地保存下来的罗马农业庄园。它们没有被圈占，没有被分割。那里有拥有巨额土地的地主，他们对农民非常不好。现在农民们正在占领庄园，为自己夺取土地，诸如此类的事情。甚至在医院里，也有中低层员工把医院老板赶出去，把高级医生赶出去，并说：“我们接管了，现在我们说了算。”这一切都关乎革命。因此，在1974年春天的政变后几周内，葡萄牙便陷入了失控状态。
the Latifundia. People say these are literally the Roman agricultural estates that have been preserved almost untouched. They haven't been enclosed. They haven't been divided up. They have massive landowners who treat their peasants very badly. And now the peasants are occupying them, taking the land for themselves, all of this kind of stuff. Even hospitals, you have sort of junior staff kicking out the bosses of the hospitals, kicking out the senior doctors and saying, we're taking over, we're in charge now. This is all about the revolution. So within weeks of the coup in the spring of 1974, Portugal is spiraling out of control.
没有人知道它将以何收场。在华盛顿特区，人们看着这一切，说道：“葡萄牙就是下一个古巴。这可能是西欧多米诺骨牌效应的开始。”因为国家元首相当右翼。是的。上尉们相当左翼。是的。但现在群众运动非常左翼。
Nobody knows where it will end. In Washington, D.C., people are looking at this and saying, Portugal is the new Cuba. This could be the beginning of some kind of domino effect through Western Europe. Because the head of state is quite right wing. Yeah. The captains are quite left wing. Yes. But now the mass movement is quite right wing. Yeah. The captains are quite left wing. Yes. But now the mass movement is very left wing.
是的。天知道事情会走向何方，汤姆？伴随着这个悬念，现在我想我们该休息一下了。嗯，这太令人兴奋了。是的，你等得对，我为催促你道歉。不，不。我们将回来寻找这个戏剧性故事的结局。
Yes. You know, who knows where it's going to go, Tom? And on that cliffhanger, now I think we should take a break. Well, that's very exciting. Yes, you were right to wait. And I apologise for trying to hurry you. No, no. We will be back to find out what the denouement is in this dramatic tale.
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《一切皆娱乐》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐行业的帷幕，向你展示这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想获得无广告收听、加更节目以及现场门票的抢先购买权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
网址是 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《一切皆历史》。我们正在葡萄牙，多米尼克正在带我们回顾“康乃馨革命”。从某种意义上说，这是我们今年早些时候制作的葡萄牙四部分系列的尾声。多米尼克，请继续。好的，所以在前半部分的结尾，葡萄牙正处于混乱之中，一个名叫斯皮诺拉将军的人掌权，还有所有这些左翼上尉，谁也不知道事情会走向何方。所以斯皮诺拉将军实际上——你知道吗，汤姆，我之前说过他参加过列宁格勒围城战，但我其实还是低估了他。他还曾在西班牙内战中站在弗朗哥将军一边作战。
That's therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are in Portugal and we are, Dominic is taking us through the Carnation Revolution. And in a way, this is a coda to the four-part series we did earlier in the year on portugal dominic take it away okay so when we ended the first half portugal was in chaos a man called general spinola was in charge the there were all these left-wing captains who knows where it's going to go so general spinola actually do you know what tom i've had i said he was at the siege of leningrad but i've actually undersold him. He'd also fought in the Spanish Civil War on General Franco's side.
好吧。而且他戴着单片眼镜。这非常丁丁历险记。是的。所以他是一个了不起的人物。他看着我刚才在前半部分开头谈到的所有那些占领事件等，然后他说：“好吧，这根本不是我所预料的。这太糟糕了。”
Okay. And he wore a monocle. That's very Tintin. Yeah. So he's a tremendous character. He watches all the occupations and stuff that I was talking about right at the beginning of the first half. And he says, well, this is not what I bargained for at all. This is very bad.
他说：“好吧，我需要引入某个人，类似于首相，来让一切平静下来。”他看中了一个家伙，他将是我们下半场的一个新角色，汤姆，名叫瓦斯科·贡萨尔维斯（Vasco Gonçalves）。现在，瓦斯科·贡萨尔维斯，我稍后会讲到他。他是一个极好的人物。他非常有趣。他是一个非常清瘦、身材高大的军人，
And he says, right, I need to bring in somebody, sort of prime minister, who will calm everything down. And he sees a bloke who's going to be a new character for us in the second half, Tom, who's called Vasco Gonçalves. Now, Vasco Gonçalves, I shall come to in a second. He's a splendid figure. He's very entertaining. He's this sort of very gaunt, sort of tall military man
出身非常富裕的背景。所以斯皮诺拉认为这家伙会很棒。你知道的，他将成为抵御激进分子的中流砥柱。结果根本不是这样。瓦斯科·贡萨尔维斯立刻说：“好吧，我们要撤出所有非洲殖民地，马上进行去殖民化。”现在，斯皮诺拉匪夷所思地——尽管他写过那本呼吁撤出非洲的书——却对此感到惊慌，他说：“嗯，我并不是指所有非洲地区，我认为我们
who's from a very rich background. So Spinola thinks this guy will be great. You know, he'll be a bulwark against the radicals. This doesn't happen at all. Vasco Goncalves immediately says, right, we'll get out of all the African colonies, decolonize straight away. Now Spin bizarrely having written that book saying let's get out of africa he's alarmed by this and he says well i didn't mean all africa i think we
其实应该保留安哥拉。”于是他们闹翻了。斯皮诺拉决定：“我要组织一场新政变，除掉这些左翼上尉。”他在1974年9月组织了这场政变，结果彻底失败了。基本上，没有人支持他。所以他是总统，但他却组织了一场针对自己政府的政变。针对他自己。而且没有成功。
should actually keep on to angola so they fall out spinola decides i'm going to organize a new coup get rid of the left-wing captains. He organizes this coup in September 1974, and it's a complete disaster. Basically, nobody turns out for him. So he's the president, but he's organized a coup against his own government. Against himself. And it hasn't worked.
所以他被迫辞职。这就是他的结局。那他后来怎么样了？嗯，有一段时间，他在葡萄牙周围潜伏了几个月。所以他没有被送去教育营什么的？不，还没有。因为在1975年3月，那是多久？大约在他上一次政变后六个月。他又尝试了一次政变。
So he's forced to resign. That's the end of him. And what happens to him? Well, for a while, he lurks around Portugal for a few months. So he doesn't get sent off to an education camp or anything? No, not yet. Because in March 1975, so what's that, about six months after his last coup? He tries another coup.
这太像《丁丁历险记》了。所以在1975年3月11日，他又尝试了一次政变。那次也没有成功。所以他先是对自己领导的政府发动了政变，又对继任政府发动了政变。对。在这一点上，他决定他也要去巴西，就像他那样的人一样。
That's very Tintin. So the 11th of March 1975, he tries another coup. That doesn't work either. So he's tried a coup against a government that he's the leader of. He's tried a coup against the successor government. Yeah. At this point, he decides he's going to go to Brazil as well, like the person that he is.
去和卡埃塔诺厮混。没错。而且，是的，他实际上在巴西试图建立一个名为“葡萄牙解放军”的组织。他极其右翼。他试图建立一个极右翼的准军事组织——所以一个右翼独裁者是一个经历了两次政变失败的左翼独裁者——是的，我想是的。所以那根本没有成功，那是他的结局，让我们忘了他吧，
Hang out with Catano. Right. And, yeah, he actually, in Brazil, he tries to set up a thing called the Liberation Army of Portugal. He's incredibly right-wing. He tries to set up an extreme right wing paramilitary group so so a right wing dictator is a left-wing dictator who's had two failed coups yeah yes i guess i guess so so that doesn't work out at all that's the end of him let's forget about him so
所以你可以把他从你的名单上划掉了。好吧，那么现在是谁在掌权葡萄牙？基本上，有两个人你需要关注。一个是奥泰罗。所以奥泰罗，我们之前谈过他。当这一切正在发生时，你敢信，他去古巴进行了一次小小的旅行？他去了古巴。他会见了菲德尔·卡斯特罗。
you can cross him off your your list okay all right so now who's in charge of portugal well basically there are two people i think you need to worry about. So one is Othello. So Othello, we talked about him before. While all this has been going on, he's gone off on a little trip to Cuba, would you believe? He goes to Cuba. He meets Fidel Castro.
这就是令CIA担心的原因。是的，确实如此。而且他见到菲德尔·卡斯特罗时高兴极了。他说：“卡斯特罗太棒了。我怎么看都看不够。”他回来了——所以奥泰罗，你还记得在前半部分里，他在萨拉查的棺木前痛哭，对吧？在1975年，也就是他那样做五年后，他从古巴回来后说：“听着，古巴人找到了正确的方法。我们应该废除所有政党，代之以革命委员会，那是通往葡萄牙幸福的道路。
And this is what the CIA are worried about. Yeah, precisely. And he is absolutely delighted to meet Fidel Castro. He says, Castro is splendid. I can't get enough of this he comes back so i'll tell her who had you know he remember in the first half he was weeping over salazar's coffin yeah in 1975 five years after he was doing that he comes back from cuba and he says listen the cumans have got the right idea we should scrap all political parties we should have revolutionary councils instead that's the the path to Portuguese happiness.
我们就这么做吧。”所以他在四处潜伏，带着所有这些计划。他是革命的某种脸面。另一个人就是我提到的那个家伙，瓦斯科·贡萨尔维斯，这个出身相当显赫的清瘦男子，斯皮诺拉曾把他引入政府却又对他感到失望。瓦斯科·贡萨尔维斯，我发现——我知道引用这个作为本期播客的资料来源是荒谬的，但这是《每日电讯报》的一段话。《每日电讯报》的讣告写道：“一个身材清瘦的军人，有着抑郁症病史，偏爱剪裁不合身的衣服和政治辞令，他持有——正如他的一位同事所说——‘你在某个相当不成熟的大学生身上才能找到的那种马克思主义观点’。
Let's do that. So he's lurking around and he's got all these plans. He's the sort of face of the revolution. The other person is that bloco I mentioned, Vasco Gonçalves, this sort of gaunt man from a very posh background who Spinola had brought in but had disappointed him. Vasco Gonçalves is, I found, I mean, I know this is a ludicrous source to be quoting in this podcast, but this is a bit from the Daily Telegraph. The Daily Telegraph obituary said, a gaunt soldier with a history of depressive illness and taste for badly fitting clothes
出生于葡萄牙繁荣的中产阶级家庭，他还拥有相当可观的财富，而这些财富奇迹般地免于他下令对他人进行没收的命运。”所以基本上，贡萨尔维斯上台了，家庭非常富有，他的左翼倾向用一种稍微——我敢不敢在不疏离听众的情况下这么说——用一种稍微有点杰里米·科尔宾（Jeremy Corbyn）的方式。他说：“好吧，我们要把一切都国有化。国有化银行、保险、石化、化肥、烟草、水泥、木材、钢铁、啤酒厂、航运、公共交通、广播、玻璃、采矿、渔业和农业部门。”现在，经济中只有两个部分免于受到他国有化计划的触及，没有被碰触。它们是外汇（即兑换货币）和建筑业。而通过这个奇迹般的巧合，他的父亲经营着一家外汇公司，
and political rhetoric, he held, as one of his own colleagues put it, quote, the sort of Marxist views you would find in a rather immature university student. Born into Portugal's prosperous middle classes, he also possessed a considerable fortune, which remained miraculously immune from the expropriation he ordered for others. So basically, Gonçalves comes in, very rich family, he's very left wing in this sort of slightly, dare dare I say without alienating my audience, a slightly Jeremy Corbyn way. He says, right, we're going to nationalize everything. Nationalize the banks, insurance, petrochemicals, fertilizers, tobacco, cement, wood, iron, steel, breweries, shipping, public transport, radio, glass, mining, fishing, and the agricultural sector. Now, there are only two parts of the economy that are immune, that are not touched by his nationalization plans. And they are foreign exchange, so changing money, and construction. And by this miraculous coincidence, his father runs a foreign exchange firm
他在其中拥有大量股份。而且他本人还亲自管理着一家巨大的建筑公司。所以这并不是对革命的一个很好的宣传。当时人们知道这件事吗？是的，大家确实都知道。所以人们对此怨声载道。于是，沉睡了这么久的葡萄牙陷入了彻底的混乱。有五十多万从非洲殖民地逃难来到葡萄牙的人。但葡萄牙人有点像比利时人那样行事。他们对自己的殖民地相当糟糕，然后突然说：“好了，我们要走了。再见。”据推测，那些从葡萄牙殖民地过来的人，他们的政治立场是否非常右翼，就像……我想他们中的一些人确实是。有些人感到受到了极大的背叛，确实如此。与此同时，在葡萄牙南部的阿连特茹，在这些巨大的农场里，农业
in which he has a large shareholding. And he also is the manager personally of a massive construction firm. So this is not a terribly good advert for the revolution. And do people know this at the time? Yeah, they do know this. So people are grumbling about it. So Portugal, which has been asleep for so long, is in utter chaos. So across half a million people have fled to Portugal from the African colonies. But the Portuguese have sort of done a Belgium. They've treated their colonies pretty badly and then suddenly said, right, we're going. Goodbye. And presumably the guys who are coming from the Portuguese colonies, are they very right wing in the way that... I think some of them are. Some of them feel terribly betrayed, exactly. Meanwhile, in the south of Portugal, in the Alentejo, in these huge farms, agricultural
工人们占领了农场，或者这些农场被没收并变成了集体农场。因此，阿连特茹大约有220万英亩的土地被他们自己的工人接管了。与此同时，政府正在把一部分土地归还给工人，又试图把一部分土地还给原主人并试图将工人们赶出去。这是一片彻底的混乱。那么苏联在这其中扮演了什么角色？有吗？这倒是个好问题。
labourers have seized the farms, or they've been confiscated and turned them into collective farms. So about 2,200,000 acres worth of the Alentejo have been taken over by their own workers. Meanwhile, the government is giving some to the workers, is trying to give some back to their owners and trying to kick out the workers. It's a complete and utter shambles. And what's the role of the Soviet Union in this? Any? That's a good question, actually.
劳动者们夺取了农场，或者这些农场被没收并改成了集体农场。因此，阿连特茹大约有220万英亩的土地被他们自己的工人接管了。与此同时，政府正试图把一些土地还给原主人，并试图把工人们赶出去。这是一场彻底的混乱。那么苏联在其中的角色是什么呢？有什么角色吗？这确实是个好问题。
I'm sure they are hovering a little bit. I mean, the Soviet Union are definitely very interested in the Portuguese colonies, so Angola and Mozambique. But in Portugal itself? In Portugal itself, I don't know. I think it's more actually the communist party i haven't mentioned the communist party so the leader of the communist party guy called alvaro cuñal he had been an exile he had come back and he's he's
我确信他们多少在附近徘徊。我的意思是，苏联对葡萄牙的殖民地，也就是安哥拉和莫桑比克，绝对非常感兴趣。但在葡萄牙本土呢？在葡萄牙本土，我不知道。我觉得实际上更多是共产党——我还没提到共产党——共产党的领袖，一个叫阿尔瓦罗·库尼亚尔的人，他曾被流放，后来回来了，而且他
again a very big player in all this his activities are reported all the time a lot of people think that he might end up being the beneficiary of all this. And he is an out-and-out, card-carrying Stalinist. You know, he's of that generation of sort of, you know, affiliated foreign communist leaders who are completely loyal, who are more Stalinist than the Stalinists, basically. So it's perfectly possible that this whole confused, chaotic story could have ended up with him in charge and Portugal veering wildly to the kind of pro-Soviet left. Now, meanwhile, Portugal is a complicated country because the North is quite
同样是这一切中的一个非常重要的角色，他的活动时刻受到报道，许多人认为他最终可能会成为这一切的受益者。而且他是一个彻头彻尾、货真价实的斯大林主义者。你知道的，他是那种与之结盟的外国共产党领袖的一代人，他们绝对忠诚，基本上比斯大林主义者还要斯大林主义。所以完全有可能，这个混乱不堪的故事最终会以他掌权而告终，葡萄牙则会急剧转向亲苏联的左翼。现在，与此同时，葡萄牙是一个复杂的国家，因为北部和南部
different from the South. And in the North, there are no big farms. The farms are much smaller. And the North is much more conservative. So that's around Porto, the Douro Valley, all that kind of stuff. And there, there is a massive backlash against the revolution. People start firebombing kind of communist or left-wing party offices and and that's where a lot of the the british that's right port families are based so is there is there mi is there mi6 involved i'm not sure i don't think taylor's dow's graham cockburns yeah exactly i don't think they're all they're all piling in i'm not saying that they are but but presumably the british government feels that britain has a stake in
截然不同。在北部，没有大农场。农场要小得多。而且北部要保守得多。所以那是在波尔图、杜罗河谷一带，诸如此类的地方。在那里，对革命产生了巨大的强烈反弹。人们开始向共产党或左翼政党的办公室投掷燃烧弹，而且——那正是很多英国——没错，波特酒家族的大本营所在。那么，是有——是有军情六处卷入吗？我不确定，我不认为泰勒道斯（Taylors）、格雷厄姆科伯恩斯（Graham Cockburns）——对，没错，我不认为他们全都蜂拥而上，我不是说他们是这样的，但是——据推测，英国政府觉得英国在
yeah what happens there we will come to britain tom you'll be delighted to hear there is a role for james callaghan in the story oh wonderful no i don't know about the british i do know about the archbishop of braga i know what he said what did he say he said this is uh this is this is a struggle not of man against man but it's a struggle of christ against satan so i mean you'd expect that from an archbishop i suppose i kind of like that language do you from from bishops i think that's how they should talk i absolutely i could not agree with you more do you hear that talk from justin will be you do not and i think that's a weakness i would like to hear more of that kind of language on thought for the Day. Yeah, it's humanists. It's all humanists now on Thought for the Day, isn't it, Tom?
那里发生的事情中有切身利益——我们稍后会谈到英国，汤姆，你一定会很高兴听到，这个故事里有詹姆斯·卡拉汉（James Callaghan）的角色。哦，太棒了，不，我对英国人不太了解，但我确实知道布拉加（Braga）大主教，我知道他说过什么。他说了什么？他说，这“这不是人与人的斗争，而是基督与撒旦的斗争”。所以我的意思是，你对大主教也会有这种期望吧。我其实挺喜欢这种语言的，你喜欢吗？从主教们那里，我觉得他们就该这么说话。当然，我不能同意你更多了。你从贾斯廷·韦尔比（Justin Welby）那里听到过这种话吗？你没有。我认为这是一个弱点。我希望在《今日灵修》（Thought for the Day）节目中听到更多这种语言。是的，都是人文主义者。现在的《今日灵修》全都是人文主义者了，对吧，汤姆？
Yeah. Sorry, we're spiralling into golf club. This is the kind of stuff that Caetano and his men were saying in Brazil. Thought for the Day. Portuguese Thought for the Day is not what it was. They've got all humanists on. It's terrible. Bring back Salazar.
是的。抱歉，我们的话题扯到高尔夫俱乐部去了。这就是卡埃塔诺（Caetano）和他的手下在巴西时说的那种话。《今日灵修》。葡萄牙的《今日灵修》已经今非昔比了。里面全都是人文主义者。太糟糕了。把萨拉查（Salazar）请回来吧。
Now, we're in the summer of 1975, and there's this kind of absolutely crazy factionalism. I know you have a horror, Tom, of acronyms.ionalism. I know you have a horror tom of acronyms. I do. There's billions of different political parties with acronyms. Can we just cut all that? There's anarchists, there's communists. Simplify that.
现在，时间来到了1975年夏天，出现了一种绝对疯狂的派系主义。我知道你对缩写词感到恐惧，汤姆。派系主义。我知道你对缩写词感到恐惧，汤姆。我是。有无数不同的政党都有缩写。我们能把这些全都省掉吗？有无政府主义者，有共产党人。简单化一点。
Skip all that. Well, this is the simplified version. What do you mean? I don't want any acronyms. Abroad, people are now looking at this with real anxiety. And they think particularly that guy, Artelo, who's come back from Cuba, absolutely fired up. They think he's going to launch some sort of new coup, you know,
跳过所有这些。好吧，这是简化版。什么意思？我不想要任何缩写。在国外，人们现在正带着真正的焦虑看着这一切。他们特别认为那个从古巴回来、斗志昂扬的奥特洛（Otelo）那家伙。他们认为他会发动某种新的政变，你知道的，
yet another coup. Yeah. And Portugal will be the Trojan horse. It'll be the sort of vanguard of communism. So this is what Time Magazine said on the 11th of August, 1975. It said, the Troika of generals that has just assumed unlimited power in Lisbon
又一次政变。是的。而葡萄牙将成为特洛伊木马。它将成为共产主义的某种先锋队。所以这是《时代》杂志在1975年8月11日所说的。它说，刚刚在里斯本取得无限权力的将军三人组
could well transform Portugal into Western Europe's first communist nation. It might well be an orthodox Marxist state, as envisaged by one of the continent's few remaining Stalinist bosses, Alvaro Cunhal. The New York Times, as we often say, Tom, never wrong in its reporting of international affairs. A communist takeover of Portugal might well encourage a similar trend in Italy and France. And presumably at this point, the New York Times wasn't in favor of that. No, no, that's right. That will come later.
很可能会把葡萄牙变成西欧第一个共产主义国家。它很可能是一个正统的马克思主义国家，正如这个大陆仅存的少数几个斯大林主义首领之一阿尔瓦罗·库尼亚尔所设想的那样。正如我们经常说的那样，汤姆，《纽约时报》在报道国际事务时从不出错。共产主义接管葡萄牙很可能会在意大利和法国引发类似的趋势。据推测，此时的《纽约时报》并不赞成这一点。不，不，没错。那要等以后。
Yeah. Affects the succession in Spain and Yugoslavia and send tremors through Western Europe. So recently declassified US State Department documents show that the CIA were sending money to officers in the army who are not so left wing. So officers who worry that the revolution is going out of control. And to the Archbishop of Braganza or whatever it was. Archbishop of Braga.
是的。影响西班牙和南斯拉夫的权力继承，并在西欧引起震动。最近解密的美国国务院文件显示，中情局曾向军队中不那么左翼的军官提供资金。也就是那些担心革命失控的军官。还提供给了布拉加（Braganza）大主教或其他什么人。布拉加（Braga）大主教。
I don't know. He's getting money from God. He doesn't need to worry about the CIA there's also a document from the 15th of September 1975 that shows a discussion between Henry Kissinger
我不知道。他从上帝那里拿钱，他不需要担心中央情报局。还有一份1975年9月15日的文件显示了亨利·基辛格（Henry Kissinger）与
Helmut Schmidt very much a friend of the rest of his history yeah and another friend of the rest of his history James Callaghan and they agree
赫尔穆特·施密特（Helmut Schmidt）——绝对是《历史的其余部分》（The Rest is History）的好朋友，是的——以及《历史的其余部分》的另一个好朋友詹姆斯·卡拉汉（James Callaghan）之间的讨论，他们一致认为
that if there is a full-scale civil war in Portugal Britain and America will send arms to anti-communist forces and send them aid because Portugal cannot be allowed to fall to the communists. And Henry Kissinger is a great sort of – we have never really done much about Henry Kissinger in the rest of his history. But you can't have a kind of 70s Cold War hotspot without Kissinger popping up.
如果葡萄牙爆发全面内战，英国和美国将向反共力量运送武器并提供援助，因为绝不能允许葡萄牙落入共产党手中。亨利·基辛格是一个伟大的——我们在《历史的其余部分》中从来没有真正对亨利·基辛格做过太多评价。但如果没有基辛格的出现，你就无法拥有一个70年代的冷战热点地区。
But Kissinger is a bit of a hysteric, I always think. Kissinger, hysteric is probably a bit unfair, partly because of his own personal background, you know, fleeing Nazi Germany and so on. He fears disaster at every turn. And he sort of thinks, oh my God, Portugal is going to go communist, Western Europe is going to collapse, all this kind of stuff. And actually, his State Department sort of thinks oh my god portugal is going to go communist western europe is going to collapse all this kind of stuff and actually his state department sort of juniors who know portugal quite well they say to kissinger you know what actually it does look very chaotic and stuff
但我总觉得基辛格有点歇斯底里。基辛格是歇斯底里，这可能有点不公平，部分原因是他个人的背景，你知道的，逃离纳粹德国等等。他每时每刻都担心灾难的降临。他某种程度上会想，天哪，葡萄牙要变成共产主义了，西欧要崩溃了，诸如此类的事情。实际上，他的国务院——那些相当了解葡萄牙的初级官员们，他们对基辛格说，你知道吗，实际上这看起来确实很混乱之类的，
but the portuguese are actually pretty conservative people and we reckon it's going to be fine don't do anything you know don't start sending in cia made with dark glasses and kind of homemade torture kits you know just hold off for a little bit because we think it'll be fine they are talking to a group called the group of nine which is a group of military officers group of nine honestly yeah i know i know you didn't want an acronym but that's not an acronym no the group i'm a sinister sounding dan brown type secret societies i'm fine with them so the group of nine are actually not very sinister they're quite centrist they're centrist dads tom like you are they yeah right that's disappointing they say uh we reject either sort of right-wing stuff or
但葡萄牙人其实相当保守，我们估计会没事的。别做什么，你知道的，别派戴着黑墨镜、带着自制酷刑工具的中情局特工进去，你知道的，先等一下，因为我们觉得会没事的。他们在和一个叫“九人组”（Group of Nine）的组织对话，这是一个由军官组成的组织。“九人组”真的吗？是的，我知道，我知道你不想用缩写，但那不是缩写。不，这个——听起来有些阴险、像丹·布朗（Dan Brown）笔下的那种秘密社团，我倒觉得没问题。所以“九人组”实际上并没有那么阴险。他们相当温和。他们是温和派的老爸们，汤姆，就像你一样。是吗？好吧，这有点令人失望。他们说，呃，我们拒绝那种右翼的东西，或者
left-wing stuff we support a model of socialism based on democracy, pluralism, and human rights. What's not to like? So that's very primary school assembly kind of – it's your kind of politics, basically. Yeah, white bread. Anodyne. So amidst all this, Vasco Gonçalves, the prime minister,
左翼的东西，我们支持一种基于民主、多元主义和人权的社会主义模式。有什么好不喜欢的？所以这非常像小学集会的调调——基本上就是你那类政治。是的，白面包。毫无特色。因此，在这一切之中，总理瓦斯科·贡萨尔维斯（Vasco Gonçalves），
the gaunt man who's nationalized everything but his own businesses, he starts to sort of crack under the strain. And he gives a speech, a famous speech, Tom, in Portuguese history, on the 18th of August, 1975, in which he starts sort of shouting and rambling wildly and says the capitalist countries want to, they're trying to put the portuguese working class they're treating them as stokers for the boilers of capitalist europe and he goes on to
这个面容憔悴、将除自己生意之外的一切都收归国有的男人，在压力下开始有点崩溃了。他发表了一场演讲，汤姆，这是葡萄牙历史上一场著名的演讲，于1975年8月18日发表。在演讲中，他开始大喊大叫，语无伦次地胡言乱语，并说资本主义国家想要，他们正试图将葡萄牙工人阶级——他们把他们当作资本主义欧洲锅炉的司炉工。接着他开始了一场
this huge rant i've actually watched on youtube now admittedly i watched it in portuguese which to tell you the truth i don't really understand so all i saw was a man in his shirt sleeves who look very like an open university lecturer from the 1970s just shouting at some students but clearly this had a great effect on people because most Portuguese people thought he's gone completely mad you know he's he's lost the plot so it's a left-wing academic having a rant yeah basically so it's it's like twitter yeah exactly that it's basically do you know what i i in in my own sort of as a real work i wrote about the polytechnic of north london in the 1970s where people were always giving rants about imperialism you know all this capitalism history man yeah very this time yeah it's just like that his his rant is just like that but he's the head of state you know
长篇大论。我其实在YouTube上看过了。当然，我承认我是用葡萄牙语看的，说实话，我其实听不懂。所以我看到的只是一个穿着衬衫袖子的男人，看起来非常像1970年代开放大学（Open University）的讲师，正对着一些学生大喊大叫。但显然这对人们产生了巨大的影响，因为大多数葡萄牙人都觉得他彻底疯了，你知道的，他已经理智全失了。所以这是一个左翼学者在大发雷霆，对，基本上就是这样。所以这就像推特一样，对，完全是这样。你知道吗，我在我自己的——作为真实工作的一部分，我在1970年代写过关于北伦敦理工学院（Polytechnic of North London）的文章，那里的人总是发表关于帝国主义的慷慨陈词，你知道的，所有这些资本主义历史，伙计。是的，非常符合那个时代。是的，就像那样。他的慷慨陈词就像那样，但他可是国家元首，你知道的。
he's the head of government sorry head. But he's the head of state. No, he's the head of government. Sorry, head of government. Who's the head of state? Another random general called General Costa Gomez. Suddenly Costa Gomez, like a tortoise from beneath his shell, emerges and sacks Fosco Gonsalves. And everybody says, oh my God, they've sacked the big man. This is civil war.
他是政府首脑，抱歉，首脑。但他不是国家元首。不，他是政府首脑。抱歉，政府首脑。谁是国家元首？另一个名叫科斯塔·戈麦斯（Costa Gomez）的随机将军。突然之间，科斯塔·戈麦斯就像一只从壳里伸出头的乌龟一样冒了出来，把瓦斯科·贡萨尔维斯给解雇了。每个人都说，天哪，他们把大人物给解雇了。这是内战。
This is going to be civil war. So by the end of August 1975, early September, basically Portugal is not working as a country. There are great mobs of people shouting in the streets all the time. Soldiers are occupying random buildings in Lisbon, sort of TV stations. They're having rallies. There's actually an amazing account of this, which gives you a sense of the sort of utter chaos of it,
这将是内战。因此，到1975年8月底、9月初，基本上葡萄牙作为一个国家已经无法运转了。大街上到处都是大群大群狂喊乱叫的人。士兵们在里斯本到处占领随机的建筑，比如电视台。他们在举行集会。其实有一个关于这方面的精彩记述，它能让你感受到那种彻头彻尾的混乱感，
by Ben Pimlott, the biographer of Harold Wilson, who is a very young man, as a student, I think, went over to Portugal to see what was going on in 1975. And he wrote a journal of the Portuguese Revolution, which you can find in Ben Pimlott's book, Frustrate Their Navistrix. And to my mind, it's actually the best essay because he wrote it when he was very young. And what it completely captures is that sense that you get in revolution. So you actually also get it in, have you read, a guy called Colin Jones wrote a book about the last day of Robespierre's life and about the end of the terror that came out about two years ago.
作者是哈罗德·威尔逊（Harold Wilson）的传记作家本·皮姆洛特（Ben Pimlott）。他当时还是个年轻人，我想作为一个学生，在1975年去葡萄牙查看发生了什么。他写了一篇《葡萄牙革命日记》，你可以在本·皮姆洛特的书《挫败他们的阴谋》（Frustrate Their Knaves）中找到。在我看来，这其实是最好的文章，因为它是他在很年轻的时候写的。它完全捕捉到的是你在革命中获得的那种感觉。所以你实际上也能在——你读过吗，一个叫科林·琼斯（Colin Jones）的人写过一本书，关于罗伯斯庇尔（Robespierre）生命中的最后一天，以及大约两年前出版的关于恐怖统治结束的书。
I've got it right here. I've got it right here. And he wrote it in the present tense. Yeah. What's great about it is that unlike most accounts of the terror that came out about two years ago. I've got it right here. I've got it right here. And he wrote it in the present tense. Yeah. What's great about it is that unlike most accounts of the French Revolution, it doesn't assume the narrative. So it captures the complete uncertainty and chaos and the way in which all kinds of contingencies could have played out differently.
我这里就有一本。我这里就有一本。他是用现在时写的。是的。棒就棒在，与大约两年前出版的大多数关于法国革命的记述不同——我这里就有一本。我这里就有一本。他是用现在时写的。是的。棒就棒在，与大约两年前出版的大多数关于法国革命的记述不同，它不预设叙事。因此，它捕捉到了彻底的不确定性和混乱，以及各种偶然性本可能走向不同结局的方式。
That's what it's like for me. I don't know what's going to happen. Well, this is what it was like. This is what it's like when you read Ben Pimlott's journal, because he describes how he just travels around lisbon and he goes from kind of occupied building to occupied building students revolutionaries anarchists right-wing officers whatever everybody's sort of occupied something or holding a rally and absolutely nobody knows what's going on i mean they're a bit like you in this podcast. They don't know who anybody is.
对我和来说就是这样的。我不知道会发生什么。好吧，事情就是这样的。当你读本·皮姆洛特的日记时，就是这种感觉，因为他描述了自己如何在里斯本四处游荡，从一个被占领的建筑走到另一个被占领的建筑——学生、革命者、无政府主义者、右翼军官，无论什么人，每个人都在占领什么东西或举行集会，绝对没有人知道发生了什么。我的意思是，他们有点像你们在这个播客里的样子。他们不知道谁是谁。
It's just a complete confusion of names. I'm waiting for the group of nine to strike. Well, this reaches its culmination in a very kind of Termidor kind of moment. So people have been waiting around. They've been waiting around to strike, just like you. Ben Pimlott's been waiting so long he actually actually goes home so his journal ends before the kind of climax um because he's i don't know his return ticket has run out of validity or whatever he's got to go and cover the labour party conference or something exactly that's probably what it is yeah but on the 25th of november othello decides to make his move and he sends paratroopers to occupy some air bases
这只是一团完全混淆的名字。我在等待“九人组”出手。好吧，这在一种非常类似于热月政变（Termidor）的时刻达到了高潮。所以人们一直在等待。他们一直在等待时机出手，就像你一样。本·皮姆洛特等了太久，以至于他实际上——他回家了。所以他的日记在高潮到来之前就结束了，呃，因为他——我不知道，他的返程机票过期了还是怎么的，他必须去报道工党会议之类的。完全正确，可能就是这样，是的。但在11月25日，奥特洛决定采取行动，他派遣伞兵去占领一些空军基地。
then was like oh my god the coup is happening it's on it's on but at the same time his opponents that later that day they launched their own counter coup is this the group of nine yeah it is the group of nine tom brilliant it is the group and everyone is piling in they're all launching coups on this day yeah and actually what happens is that Othello's men are overpowered. But no casualties? And this is the thing. There are no casualties. That's amazing.
当时的人们心想，天哪，政变正在发生，要开始了，要开始了！但与此同时，他的对手在当天晚些时候发动了他们自己的反政变。这就是“九人组”吗？是的，这就是“九人组”，汤姆，太棒了，这就是那个组织。每个人都蜂拥而上，他们都在这一天发动政变。是的，实际上发生的情况是奥特洛的手下被压制了。但没有人员伤亡？这就是关键所在。没有人员伤亡。这太惊人了。
So after those four people who died on the very first day, basically nobody really has been killed. There's been no fighting. And I was thinking about this because when we did our Salazar podcast, we were talking about Salazar and his authoritarianism. And we mentioned in that how actually the death toll figures in Portugal under Salazar's admittedly extremely repressive and pretty unpleasant regime, the death toll figures by the standards of 20th century regimes are pretty low, a few hundred maybe, if you put aside the colonial wars.
所以在第一天死那四个人之后，基本上没有人真正被杀。没有任何战斗。我在想这件事，因为当我们做关于萨拉查的播客时，我们在谈论萨拉查和他的威权主义。我们在其中提到，实际上在萨拉查那个公认极其压抑且相当令人不快的政权下，葡萄牙的死亡人数按20世纪政权的标准来看是相当低的抛开殖民战争不谈，大概也就几百人。
And I wonder whether the fact that Portugal actually, by 20th century European standards, had had a pretty quiescent kind of stagnant history, whether that plays a part in all this. Because people are most likely to be violent when they're frightened of violence against themselves. And because it's never started, never does start if you see what right it's an extraordinary thing that nobody dies there's incredible lack of violence throughout all this so this 25th of november 1975 coup this is the real turning point basically artello had
我在想，葡萄牙按20世纪欧洲的标准来看，曾有过一段相当平静、停滞的历史，这个事实是否在这一切中发挥了作用。因为人们最有可能在害怕针对自己的暴力时表现出暴力。而且因为暴力从未开始，如果你明白的话——从来就不会开始。没有人死亡真是一件非同寻常的事，在这一切当中有着不可思议的缺乏暴力。所以1975年11月25日的这场政变，这才是真正的转折点。基本上奥特洛
launched this coup this was his chance to be the castro there are no shots fired. He's just rounded up and put into prison. And a new guy who had been a key figure in the counter coup, you don't have to worry about him, Tommy, we won't talk about him very much. Antonio Romalho Iannas, he becomes the big man. He gets the support of the Socialist Party, so sort of centre-left rather than hard-left, and centre-right social democrats. He's Macron. I think that's a pretty weird parallel, but... But he's kind of centrist.
发动了这场政变，这是他成为卡斯特罗的机会。没有开枪。他只是被抓获并关进了监狱。而另一个在反政变中发挥了关键作用的新人——你不用担心他，汤姆，我们不会过多谈论他——安东尼奥·拉马略·埃亚内斯（Antonio Ramalho Eanes），他成了大人物。他得到了社会党（也就是激进左翼之外的中左翼）和中右翼社会民主党的支持。他是马克龙。我觉得这是一个相当奇怪的类比，不过……但他某种程度上是温和派。
Yes, I guess he's kind of centrist. So, Othello comes out of prison after a little while. They have an election in 1976, presidential election. Romaglio Iannis wins 62% of the vote. Othello wins only 16%. And he gets all that from the Alentejo, from the areas, very poor, very rural, where peasants had occupied the big farms. And with that, after all this chaos and all this confusion, with that, it's as though they've pricked a balloon and the air just completely seeps out. And thenugal joins the the ec exactly um and the rest is history well there's another presidential election in 1980 again the same two this time uh romaglio ianis wins an absolutely stonking majority
是的，我想他算是温和派。所以，奥特洛过了一段时间后出狱了。他们在1976年举行了选举，即总统选举。拉马略·埃亚内斯赢得了62%的选票。奥特洛只赢得了16%。而且他所有的选票都来自阿连特茹（Alentejo），来自那些非常贫穷、非常偏远的地区，那里的农民曾占领过大农场。随着这一切的发生，经历了所有的混乱和迷茫之后，这一切就像是人们戳破了一个气球，空气彻底漏光了。然后葡萄牙加入了欧洲共同体，对，呃——历史就这样继续了。好吧，1980年还有另一场总统选举，同样是这两个人，这一次，埃亚内斯以绝对压倒性的多数获胜，
artelo wins only one percent oh so i said to you that his career would end on an interestingly interesting trajectory he's very disappointed by all this because in 1975 he had clearly thought you know he was going to be the master of portugal he does what everybody does when they've lost in this period he becomes involved he goes even further to the extreme and becomes involved with the sort of terrorist paramilitary group so he sets up a group called the Popular Forces of the 25th of April. The 25th of April is the sacred day, the Carnation Revolution, when it all kicked off. They do what sort of left-wing terrorist groups do in the 70s and 80s. They organize bank robberies and bombings and stuff like that.
奥特洛只获得了百分之一的选票。哦，所以我对你讲过，他的职业生涯将以一个有趣得多的轨迹结束。他对这一切感到非常失望，因为在1975年时，他显然认为（你知道的）自己将成为葡萄牙的主宰。他做出了所有在这个时期失利的人都会做的事：他参与了进去，变得更加极端，并参与了一个类似恐怖准军事组织的团体。所以他建立了一个名为“4月25日人民力量”（Popular Forces of the 25th of April）的组织。4月25日是个神圣的日子，也就是康乃馨革命（Carnation Revolution）爆发的日子。他们做着70、80年代左翼恐怖组织所做的事情：策划银行抢劫、爆炸案之类的事情。
Kidnappings of children of industrialists. I don't know if they did do any kidnappings, but they did actually kill 14 people in their in their bombing so there is some some death toll later on yeah um he is put in prison eventually he's caught othello he i mean it's a weird thing because he's kind of the face of the revolution that the portuguese celebrate to this day but he then has kind of disgraced himself he's put in prison and then in the 1990s he's given an amnesty but this may give you some sense about why his political career didn't turn out as successfully as he had hoped he is a man of a degree of unreliability tom
绑架实业家的孩子。我不知道他们是否真的绑架过人，但他们在爆炸案中确实杀害了14人，所以后来确实有一定的人员伤亡。是的，呃——他最终被关进了监狱，奥特洛被抓了。我的意思是，这是一件很奇怪的事，因为他某种程度上是葡萄牙至今仍在庆祝的革命的门面，但他后来却名誉扫地，被关进监狱。然后在20世纪90年代，他获得了特赦。但这或许能让你明白为什么他的政治生涯并没有像他所希望的那样成功：他是一个相当不可靠的人，汤姆。
right because he by the time he was imprisoned he was was married. But he met a female prison warder in the prison whom he also married. So he was a bigamist. Right. And he lived with his original wife on his release from Thursday to Sunday. And then he would go and live with the other wife, the prison warder, from Monday to Thursday. And was she still a prison warder? That's a good question, actually question actually i don't know i don't know if she was still working at prison that would be very weird wouldn't it quite odd yeah he well two other things um you asked if
没错，因为在他入狱的时候，他已经结婚了。但他在监狱里遇到了一名女狱警，后来也和她结婚了。所以他是个重婚者。没错。他出狱后，从星期四到星期天和他的原配妻子住在一起。然后从星期地到星期四，他会去和另一个妻子——那个女狱警一起住。她当时还是个狱警吗？这倒是个好问题，实际上我不知道她当时是否还在监狱工作。那不是很奇怪吗？相当奇怪，是的。呃，还有另外两件事，你问过
he was on strictly he wasn't on strictly but he established a sideline appearing in erotic films so okay that's a that's quite a sort of, he must've been what? He was born in, I think, late 1930s. So he's in his 60s, 70s by the time he's appearing in these porn films.
他有没有参加过《严格来舞》（Strictly Come Dancing）？他没有参加过《严格来舞》，但他开辟了一条副业，出现在色情电影中。所以，好吧，这算是一种——他当时一定多大年纪？他出生于，我想是在20世纪30年代末。所以当他出现在这些色情电影中时，他已经六七十岁了。
I suppose. If you've got it. He was in a film called The Failed Revolution, which I haven't seen, but I read online that it involves him, and I quote, nuzzling a woman on a floor strewn with carnations. Oh,
我想也是。如果你宝刀未老的话。他演过一部名叫《失败的革命》（The Failed Revolution）的电影，我没看过，但我在线上读到，里面有他——我引述一下——“在一片洒满康乃馨的地板上亲昵地厮磨一个女人”。哦，
so this is, this is the erotic film? Yeah. It's not a documentary about? About the revolution. About the revolution? No. But it nods to his revolutionary past because it has the carnations.
所以这就是——这就是那部色情电影？是的。这不是一部关于什么的纪录片？关于革命的？关于革命的？不是。但它向他的革命过去致敬，因为它里面有康乃馨。
Yeah, of course. And when he's nuzzling, as the thing describes it, there are carnations present and perhaps the revolutionary symbols. And then the group of nine burst in. Unexpected twist. Anyway, he was very disappointed by what happened to portugal he died only last year tom and uh do you know what
对，当然。正如描述所说，当他进行厮磨时，现场有康乃馨，也许还有革命的象征。然后“九人组”破门而入。意想不到的转折。无论如何，他对葡萄牙发生的事情感到非常失望，他去年才去世，汤姆，呃，你知道吗，
he said before he died um let's have a coup he said uh portugal needs a good financial manager a man with intelligence and honesty like antonio salazar just without the fascism. God. So he'd gone full circle. He had. He'd gone absolutely full circle. Meanwhile, Portugal had become, you know, after that sort of crazy two years, just became a completely, you know, successful, incredibly successful, prosperous member of the European Union.
他在死前说了什么？呃——“我们来搞一次政变吧。”他说，呃，“葡萄牙需要一个优秀的财务经理，一个像安东尼奥·萨拉查那样既聪明又诚实的人，只是不要有法西斯主义。”天哪。所以他又转了一圈回到了原点。是的。他真的转了一圈回到了原点。与此同时，葡萄牙在经历了那场疯狂的两年之后，已经变成了一个完全的、你知道的，非常成功、极其成功、繁荣昌盛的欧盟成员国。
So it all ended happily. I mean, everybody kind of got, he got two wives. He got to appear in the erotic film yes yes yeah loads of people hanging out in in rio yeah which i'm sure you know worst places to be yeah in our glasses kind of moaning about humanist thought for the day and what happens to the group of nine they ran they basically they they i suppose they set the you love the group of nines i thought did they have kind of handshakes and secret codes? I don't think they do.
所以这一切都有了一个美满的结局。我的意思是，每个人都——他娶了两个妻子，他还得以出演色情电影，是的，是的，是的。还有许多人在里约闲逛，我知道那里绝对不是最糟糕的地方。戴着黑墨镜，抱怨着《今日灵修》里的人文主义者。那“九人组”后来怎么样了？他们基本上——我猜他们设立了——你不是很喜欢“九人组”吗？我以为他们会有某种秘密握手和暗号呢？我觉得他们没有。
I don't think they do. I think maybe they still get together and they kind of, you know, drink a toast to Henry Kissinger or something. Anyway, they're sort of moderate officers. And they're kind of, I guess, the moderate center of Portuguese public opinion. They basically set the tone for the rest of Portuguese history. Well, wonderful, Dominic.
我觉得他们没有。我想也许他们现在还会聚在一起，然后，你知道的，为亨利·基辛格干一杯什么的。无论如何，他们是一群温和派军官。他们某种程度上，我猜是葡萄牙公众舆论的温和中间派。他们基本上为葡萄牙历史的其余部分定下了基调。好吧，太棒了，多米尼克。
Thank you very much. So now we've done the whole of Portugal, haven't we? We've done the whole of Portugal. From the Carthaginians up to the erotic film
非常感谢。所以现在我们把葡萄牙的整个历史都讲完了，对吧？我们讲完了整个葡萄牙的历史。从迦太基人一直讲到奥特洛的色情电影。
of Othello. Well, brilliant. What a story. Thanks very much. Thank you very much, Dominic. Thank you, everyone, for listening. And obviously,
真是太棒了。多么精彩的故事。非常感谢。非常感谢你，多米尼克。也谢谢大家的收听。显然，
we'll be back tomorrow with more of this stuff. so we'll see you then bye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, a splash of showbiz gossip.
我们明天会带着更多精彩内容回归。所以我们到时见，再见！感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。想要获取独家单集、抢先收听、无广告体验以及我们的聊天社区权限，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及少许的八盒八卦。
And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家单集以及抢先购买现场门票的权益，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。